à l'abri du tumulte de la ville se cache
au pied des arbres des mini maison
il ya quelques mois ce couple a quitté
la région parisienne et racheter 5
hectares de terrain au coeur de la forêt
d'orléans ils y ont construit ce que
l'on appelle des tiny house
une tania c'est une petite habitation
c'est un courant qui vient des états
unis qui est lié à beaucoup de crises
économiques notamment de crise du
logement où on a commencé à se demander
comment on fait pour réduire son impact
réduire sa consommation aussi pour des
raisons évidemment financière et comment
faire pour vivre avec moi et de tout ce
mouvement philosophique et n'est en fait
ces différentes habitations moins de 20
mètres carrés de superficie dédiée aux
courts séjours une décoration par un
artiste différent pour chacune des huit
cabanes montagne à samedi ont été
fabriqués en france avec du bois du
massif central et on a vraiment fait
travailler tous les producteurs locaux
dans les moindres détails et par exemple
peuvent vous voyez la vaisselle en fait
elle a été réalisée à la main par une
artisans qui s'appelle sandra gagné un
concept qui séduit les vacanciers
on voit que c'est réfléchi et que c'est
fait par des passionnés puisque jusqu'au
vos sets de ce qu'on va manger jusqu'au
aux matériaux qui sont utilisés à
l'intérieur aux produits d'entretien
avant là tout est vraiment fait qu'un
esprit pour se dire ça fait réfléchir et
puis ça ça nous invite à être plus
respectueux de la nature c'est aussi
l'idée de du lieu et le secteur est en
plein développement il existerait
aujourd'hui en france environ 500
émirats ou peut-être une nouvelle façon
de se ressourcer en pleine nature